We are racing for a hundred-dollar bill.
Before I say go, I'm gonna make a couple of statements.
If those statements apply to you,...
...I want you to take two steps forward.
If those statements don't apply to you,...
...I want you to stay right where you're at.
Take two steps forward if both of your parents are still married.
Take two steps forward if you grew up with a father figure in the home.
Take two steps forward if you had access to a private education.
Take two steps forward...
...if you never had to help mom or dad with the bills.
Take two steps forward if you never wondered...
...where your next meal was gonna come from.
I want you guys up here in the front just to turn around and look.
Every statement I've made has nothing to do...
...with anything any of you have done.
We all know these people up here have a better opportunity...
...to win these hundred dollars.
Does that mean these people back here can't race?
No.
We would be foolish to not realize...
...we've been given more opportunity.
We don't want to recognize that we've been given a head start.
But the reality is we have.
Now, there's no excuse.
They still got to run their race.
You still got to run your race.
But whoever wins this hundred dollars,...
...I think it'd be extremely foolish of you...
...not to utilize that and learn  more about somebody else's story.
Because the reality is, if this was a fair race,...
...and everybody's back on that line,...
...I guarantee you, some of these black dudes will smoke all of you.
And it's only because you have this big of a head start,...
...that you're possibly gonna win this race called life.
That is a picture of life, ladies and gentlemen.